allocations de chômage ouais comme tous
les mois quoi faire la routine quoi
mais ça fait longtemps vous venez vous
ça fait bien six en avatar dont j'avais
raison vous rentrez dans votre septième
année de pointage déjà comble temps
passe et ben dis donc ça nous rajeunit
pas tout ça va dit non je me rappelle
les débuts quand je venais pointer là il
y avait votre petite nièce
quand elle va mal c'est que moi a dit et
je les connais autres comme ça va
valider a grandi elle va rentrer en 6e
bonbons et vous comment ça va toujours
mon train-train jours ici un jour là les
patrons de travail encore n'ont rien
rires
pourtant c'est pas la place qui manque
on va vous savez les meilleures places
elles ont déjà été prises
les types n'ont pas attendu les places à
800 mille sept cent mille six cent mille
par mois ils se sont servis rhin il
arrive trop tard et vous cherchez bien
mais surtout les matins je vais je
demande bon je me suis ivre espagne face
à 800 milles au moment mais je sais déjà
pris et à 700 milles à ces prix il ya
600 milles ces prix gémeaux gym madame
thérèse à 200 millions n'a pas et bien
vous savez à 70 à 80 millions à plein
des places est là pourquoi pour qu'elle
a plein pourquoi personne n'en veut
gyneco par mois je le redis à livrer à
des places en boîte mais là on veut pas
nouvelle fatwa va quoi il me dit on veut
pas d'un billet non on s'y fait on s'y
fait on s'y fait vous savez l'après midi
ce beau cinéma je reste deux ou trois
séances bien au chaud et puis quand
c'est fini je descends il arrive
doucement doucement cette heure je
descends café je regarde la télévision
jusqu'à la fin en noir et blanc lé
programme parce que la couleur là bas
ils vont nous la livrée que le mois
prochain
cette ordure et puis comme ça j'en suis
moins fait allez on se dit aujourd'hui
mardi
ça vous fait coucher tard tout ça et oui
et oui mais je sens qu'il va arriver
dans mon jeu pourrait plus le faire ça
je le sens je le sens mais dit-il matin
l'or heureusement je peux récupérer le
matin je me lève vers les 10 heures 11
heures
je vais faire un petit tour à la mairie
je le vois aussi repenser son cours a
touché
bien retard d'allocations ça dépasse
qu'administration n'est jamais
tranquille autant paperasserie là quand
il ya des élections je vais voter je
regarde les buts un jeu passe la matinée
des candidats y en a toujours des
nouveaux challenges ragga cela tient
aussi laissé pointer offs il arrivait
nouveau ben si tu petites découvertes et
oui mais les élections c'est tout l'état
on sait qu'on est mieux que rien mais
vous savez le plus dur c'est pas ça le
plus dur c'est de 15 le 14 juillet le 15
août le 1er mai aux new yorkais ce qu'on
s'ennuie les magasins fermés personnes
au travail est un calvaire
les longues journées à ça c'est très
long les jours fériés je peux pas les
voir
mais quand même votre famille vous la
voyez de temps en temps vos frères et
vos soeurs mais bon ils travaillent tous
eux il se lève à 6h du matin le travail
en banlieue ont aussi des artistes soit
disant et part en tournée toujours à
droite à gauche
ma soeur elle travaille dans le métro
elle fera nuit soit disant qu'ils
appellent ça des brigades savoir que si
ces brigades là qui font ça fait que je
peux pas les voir on n'a pas les mêmes
horaires
tous deux problèmes et nous en émoi
surtout on voit surtout moi aussi voilà
votre argent monsieur albert dites moi
oui
vous savez vous savez pas si on va être
augmentée prochainement
ah non j'ai rien entendu à ce sujet
comment vous avez entendu ça tu ne sais
pas comment tous les fonctionnaires il a
été augmenté et tous les collègues
m'avaient chine où normalement on doit
suivre alors c'est à chez nous y'a rien
d'annoncé un ben ça c'est de l'abus
comme ami à tige un ça va aller mal hein
tout ce qui leur paraissait trop en
faire la grève mais attention nous
confond fait la grèce et peu de rigolade
n ont fait la grève illimitée noah
attention